good morning I have been having so much
fun starting off my day is basically
just hopping out here flying the drone
getting some incredible shots I hope you
guys aren't sick of the drone shots
because it's uh it's so much fun if
you've never flown one it's
life-changing I'm a little distraught
because yesterday I tried to use my
maverick channel just told me that she
was gonna throw my drone into the ocean
I may have floated in some extreme wind
conditions so friends that's why I'm
using my phantom 4 and I'm reckless so
here we're gonna oh my why are you not
on let's calibrate this baby boy ready
to go GPS has been updated please check
it out great
you
[Music]
that was quite a successful flight if I
do say so myself and uh I do say this
whole I gotta get into the store for
he's really excited about the fruit
though I got a high ponytail today
feeling real wild where we going
is it a palm tree little baby pong holy
moly it's really warm I probably should
have slathered more sunscreen on my bod
look worst tracks track of the horse
where's the creature what do you think
it was a reptile it was a teeny teeny
he was Nene crossing Oh horsies they're
so pretty
Mike knowing this is gonna be an
extensive hike I would not have brought
a can of Gharib amate the weather has
been so perfect this week I'm so hot I
would hop in that forgive me a basin of
water immediately
[Music]
did you get the shot free good girl I
had to put my your of amate oh you guys
see it
I had a boredom idea no garbage cans out
here in the wilderness very nice house
we're halfway there
Wow fruit thighs what is that I don't
know what tell us what it is not you I
tell the Internet they know everything
we just got a fresh coconut gen Ewell me
to get some drone shot to you
cool do you think I should drone from
the pool
let me contemplate this you going out
there I don't know you didn't think this
through I didn't think it through and I
can't freaking see this is not think
about that's gonna be on your gravestone
tombstone this is something I did not
think about
[Music]
I can't see
no idea
[Music]
hi guys not working out the way that I
great sunsets light everyone where we go
now lejano bring us to some shops and I
don't know what else we're gonna do
we're gonna see I feel like there's got
to be some shave ice involved oh my god
who has a punch card the way I want to
go to get I'm a dull wet you gotta shut
your mouth please go get the dole way
you're gonna you're gonna get hit
go get a single smash oh oh
pinkie cookie jar we've got her coffee
so now we're gonna just see what series
eight Thor free Jenna dad huh for sale
$55,000 what are you gonna do with it
Oh get out of here you this guy look so
excited about I look at Brees making us
I'll do the purple dog one Oh the jobs
hit the convoy yeah but I want this one
by this one but I want this one for your
working real hard I know she's gonna do
forever okay let us know how it works
out for you let's talk about you I'm
sorry we can't now the music started it
was a good chat good idea is very good
and monitor doing is that is really cute
we did make fun of you we're sorry brain
very nice very cute so thoughtful and
sharp your spell
that's cute Ryan's little grace tuxedo
let's get the doll wet let's get the
doll we're out of my face
let's get the doll web let's get it all
wet
Justine did you just drop your camera in
there you have to go get them canner I
called it you did you actually did call
it I would have dove in there just taken